ich rufe auf die Tagesordnungspunkte 7a
bis 7D Beratung von Vorlagen zur
Einführung einer Preisbremse für Erdgas
Wärme und Strom sowie einer Studierenden
energiepreispauschale zu dem Entwurf
eines studieren einer Studierenden
energiepreispauschalgesetzes liegt ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
vor
für die Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von
68 Minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne nun die Aussprache
und zuerst beginnt für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen Frau Dr Ingrid
Nestle
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir bringen
heute das Gesetz des Paket zur
gaspreisbremse und strompreisbremse ein
die Menschen und Unternehmen in diesem
Land können sich auf die Ampel verlassen
Putin Putin hat diesen Kontinent in eine
sehr schwierige Lage gebracht und
Deutschland durch eine Kombination von
absichtlich hochgetriebenen Preisen für
fossile Energien in Mischung mit einer
Desinformationskampagne daran sein gar
nicht die fossilen oder Putin Schulz
sondern ach wahrscheinlich der neuer
waren oder der Klimaschutz dieses Land
in eine sehr schwierige Lage gebracht
und ja dass sie jetzt hier von ganz
rechten Rand überfahren das ist sehr
bezeichnet denn als ein sie sind sie
diejenigen die Putins
Desinformationskampagne sogar hier
unterstützt und das fügt diesem Land
wirklich schweren Schaden zu
liebe liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
können die Folgen von Putins Angriffen
nicht ausradieren aber wir können sie
sehr wohl mildern wir können dafür
sorgen dass unsere Gesellschaft nicht
daran zerbricht dass der und die
einzelnen nicht allein gelassen sind und
unsere Wirtschaft stabilisiert wird und
da möchte ich mich ganz zuvorderst
bedanken beim Wirtschafts- und
Energieministerium die in wirklich
wirklich grandioser sehr harte Arbeit
diese Entwürfe arbeitet haben und ich
finde sie haben eine ganze Reihe sehr
sehr gute Aspekte
erstens die Entlastung kommt automatisch
niemand muss Anträge stellen niemand
muss Formulare ausfüllen nein das Geld
kommt automatisch bei Ihnen zu Hause an
zweitens wer Gas und Strom spart spart
auch weiterhin Geld und ja auch das ist
wichtig denn damit wir gut durch diesen
und den nächsten Winter kommen ist es
weiterhin wichtig dass wir alle
gemeinsam auf Solidarität ich saß noch
mal weil es hier ständig falsch
unterstellt wird nicht die Leute mit
wenig Geld müssen sparen weil sie kein
Geld haben wir alle als Gesellschaft
auch gerade die Reichen in Solidarität
denn mit wir mit den knappen Gas durch
diesen und den nächsten Winter kommen
müssen wir Gas und Strom sparen und
deswegen ist es richtig und wichtig dass
in diesem Entwurf dafür gesorgt wird
dass diejenige die das tun auch
tatsächlich wahres Geld behalten
drittens
drittens finde ich es sehr gut dass mit
diesem Gesetz alle entlastet werden
Menschen Unternehmen Kommunen und ohne
eine komplizierte Unterscheidung wer zu
welcher Gruppe gehört nein wir gucken
lediglich was sind die Gruppe mit hohen
Verbrauch was ist die mit niedrigen
Verbrauch und ich halte diesen Ansatz
für sehr intelligent und sehr effizient
er sorgt für klare Kommunikation und
macht die Umsetzung in so kurzer Zeit
überhaupt erst möglich
wichtig ist uns auch
dass die Subventionen bei den Reichen
besteuert wird das Jahr das gerade
besonders viel Geld bei denen ankommt
die wenig davon haben das besonders viel
dort ankommt wo es am dringendsten
benötigt wird
wir werden uns
wir werden uns darüber hinaus im
parlamentarischen Verfahren dafür
einsetzen dass auch die Unternehmen die
sehr große Unterstützung bekommen in
dieser Zeit keine Boni und
dividendenausschützen für ausschütten
dürfen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen dieses
Gesetzespaket organisiert Solidarität
und dazu gehört auch dass diejenigen die
sehr hohe Gewinne gemacht haben durch
die hohen Energiepreise ihren Beitrag
leisten in einem anderen Gesetz dass wir
nicht hier diskutieren geht es dabei um
die Gewinne der Ölkonzerne hier und
heute geht es um die Gewinne im
Strombereich
und dort werden alle alle
relevanten stromerzeugungstechnologien
abgeschöpft bei denen etwas abzuschöpfen
gibt und ja das sind nicht Gas und
Steinkohle Gas ganz evident deshalb
nicht weil wir wegen Gaskraftwerke
überhaupt dieses ganze Problem haben da
ist nichts abzuschöpfen aber auch die
Steinkohle ist sehr wäre sehr wenig zu
holen und würden wir dieses wenige holen
bestünde die ernste Gefahr dass
tatsächlich wieder viel mehr
Gaskraftwerke statt der Kohlekraftwerke
laufen dass wir viel mehr Gas
verbrauchen in eine mangelage Rauschen
und das wäre kritisch
es wird mitunter behauptet wir würden am
meisten bei der Erneuerbaren holen nein
wir besteuern hier oder wir schöpfen
nicht explizit bei den Erneuerbaren ab
wir schöpfen bei allen
stromerzeugungstechnologien ab wo es
geht aber ja die Erneuerbaren liefern
tatsächlich am meisten weil die
Erneuerbaren den größten Anteil an der
Stromversorgung stellen und weil sie bei
weitem am kostengünstigsten sind und das
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind zwei
sehr gute Nachrichten
sie zeigen sie zeigen auch wie dringend
für die Erneuerbaren brauchen für die
Zukunft für die preisgünstigkeit für die
Versorgungssicherheit für den
Klimaschutz und deswegen legen wir
großen Wert darauf mit diesem
Gesetzespaket auch gute
Investitionsbedingungen für die Zukunft
für die Erneuerbaren zu schaffen hier
wird nichts abgeschreckt wir haben gute
sicherheitsmarschen festgelegt das kann
man vielleicht schon daran sehen dass
wir von geschätzten 90 Milliarden
Zufalls gewinnen 20 Milliarden
abschöpfen ja wir brauchen die
Erneuerbaren und wichtig ist vor allem
dass wir gute Investitionsbedingungen
für die Zukunft schaffen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es wird
auch manchmal gesagt warum gibt es zwei
unterschiedliche Werte für Braunkohle
das gucken wir uns an genau wie die
Werte für Atom ich sage nur schon mal
diejenigen die sich beschweren das
andere mehr kriegen die können selbst in
Kohleausstieg auf 20 30 vorziehen dann
bekommen Sie auch den hören werden
ich komme zum Abschluss dieses Gesetz
kann nicht perfekt sein würden wir auf
das perfekte Gesetz warten würden wir
gar nichts beschließen und die Menschen
Unternehmen in diesem Land allein lassen
das Gesetz kann nicht perfekt sein aber
es macht diese Regierung auch dass sie
trotzdem handelt wo Handeln notwendig
ist und das ist ein großes Glück für
unser Land in dieser Zeit Putin hat sich
das anders gedacht er hat gehofft dass
unsere Demokratie schon in diesem Winter
zusammenbricht aber die Menschen in
diesem Land sind bereit für Solidarität
unser Land ist stark und die Ampel ist
bereit die notwendige Unterstützung zu
organisieren herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Andreas Jung
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die Energiepreise sind
explodiert vor allem weil Putin Energie
als Waffe gegen uns einsetzt dem müssen
wir die Stirn bieten und deshalb ist es
richtig und notwendig zu begrenzen zu
decken zu bremsen als Union fahren wir
seit Monaten diese Preis bremsen und
soweit sie umgesetzt werden unterstützen
wir das Trinken wir darauf dass sie
beschleunigt umgesetzt werden und darauf
dass es klare Regelungen gibt insoweit
haben Sie unsere Unterstützung
aber die Art und Weise wie sie es
umsetzen er Finanzminister die wirft
viele Fragen auf wir machen es in
Deutschland komplizierter als alle
anderen in Europa es ist ein gemeinsames
europäisches Vorhaben Preise zu
begrenzen wir machen es aber
komplizierter als alle anderen wenn sie
so umsetzen dann werden wir zum
Europameister für bürokratische
Umsetzung und das kann nicht sein
deshalb muss der nachgebessert werden
deshalb müssen die Regelung klarer
werden in der Lindner ich frage mich sie
machen diese komplizierten Regelungen
sie sind doch der Finanzminister doch
sie sind zuständig für die
Mehrwertsteuer warum warum Herr Lindner
geben Sie nicht ein ganz klares Signal
die Mehrwertsteuer wird gesenkt für alle
und zwar nicht für die beim Gas und für
Fernwärme aber beim Strom wiederum nicht
beim Öl auch nicht eine klare Botschaft
dafür sind sie zuständig setzen sie sich
um Mehrwertsteuer runter für alle
Energieträger das wäre ein wichtiger
und wir unterstützen strompreisbremse
wir unterstützen gaspreisbremse aber wir
sind gegen die Erneuerbaren Bremse die
da vorgelegt wird was sie hier machen
Ingrid Nestler gerade von
Investitionssicherheit gesprochen das
beschädigt des Vertrauen in
Investitionen in erneuerbare Energien
und die werden jetzt schon
zurückgestellt und oh doch es ist so
dass erneuerbare in diesem Paket
schlechter behandelt werden es die
fossilen schlechter behandelt werden als
die Kernenergie nirgends soll so
abgeschöpft werden wie bei den
erneuerbaren Energien und das darf nicht
sein da habe ich wollte
Herr Habig und die Ampel wollte doch mit
dem osterpaket den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien beschleunigen das
wird mit diesem Winter eingerissen es
wird Vertrauen beschädigen deshalb muss
man da noch mal ran und ich will ihnen
sagen in welchen Punkten
gerade ist gesprochen würden wir
schöpfen Gewinne ab ne das ist nicht
richtig bei den großen Konzern Mineralöl
Gas da werden Gewinne abgeschafft aber
hier werden Erträge abgeschöpft es
werden fiktive Erträge abgeschöpft was
vermutlich verfassungswidrig ist ist
aber jedenfalls in der Sache falsch weil
damit Geld abgeschöpft wird es ist in
vielen Fällen gar nicht gibt nehmen Sie
die Bioenergie sie nehmen die Steinkohle
aus die
co2-ausstoßende Steinkohle aber die
nachhaltige Bioenergie die wird so
gedeckelt dass die Grundlage für den
weiteren Betrieb in Frage gestellt ist
und deshalb müssen sie da noch mehr
Range brauchen eine tragfähige Grundlage
für die Bioenergie das was danach
gebessert wurde reicht bei weitem nicht
die haben Kostensteigerung in ganz
erheblichem Umfang das muss
berücksichtigt werden gehen sie da noch
mal an wir brauchen einen Grundlage für
ein beschleunigtenausbau der
Erneuerbaren und keine Deckelung der
erneuerbaren Energien
und dasselbe gilt für die Kraft
wärmekopplung die Kraft wärmekupplung
ist der verlässliche Partner für
volatile erneuerbare Energien und den
entziehen sie jetzt rückwirkend die
Grundlage dadurch dass sie die
Netzentgelte die die bisher nicht
bezahlen müssen die sollen die jetzt
bezahlen und damit werden vermutlich
viele dieser Anlagen abgestellt werden
und ausfallen in einer Situation in der
wie Sie gerade brauchen besser und sieht
es nach wir brauchen hier
Verlässlichkeit wir brauchen Vertrauen
und wir brauchen im übrigen
parlamentarische Entscheidung und nicht
die Delegation wichtiger Entscheidung an
diese Regierung sie legen hier vor ein
Gesetz in dem sie die Bundesregierung
ermächtigen wollen zu entscheiden ob das
was sie zur Abschöpfung vorliegen ob das
7 Monate gilt oder 17 Monate sieben
Monate oder 17 Monate meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren da ist doch
der kernparlam Herrscher Bestimmung
gefragt ich appelliere an ihr
Selbstverständnis als Abgeordnete nehmen
Sie hier parlamentarische Rechte weil es
kann nicht sein dass die Regierung Herr
Lindner Herr Habeck und Olaf Scholz in
der Suppenküche der Bundesregierung
darüber entscheiden ob 7 oder 17 Monate
bei erneuerbaren Energien abgeschaffte
das muss hier entschieden werden hier
schlägt das Herz der Demokratie ist eine
parlamentarische Entscheidung und
deshalb im Grundsatz Strom und Gaspreis
können Sie richtig falsch dass die ganze
Gruppen ausschließen bei Pellets und
beim Öl da muss was gemacht werden aber
insbesondere müssen sie da noch mehr ran
wir brauchen eine Verlässlichkeit wir
brauchen Vertrauen dass es entscheiden
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Matthias Miersch
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Kollege jung das ist
richtig dass die Opposition auch Dinge
anmerkt aber von Suppenküche etc zu
reden von Suppenküche etc zu reden das
ist schon ein bisschen sage ich mal wenn
man sich die Konzeption der CDU und CSU
der letzten Monate mal in diesem Haus
anguckt was die Bewältigung dieser Krise
anbelangt dann wäre ich an ihrer Stelle
ein bisschen vorsichtiger das erste was
diese Regierung und diese Koalition
geleistet hat ist dass wir
Versorgungssicherheit sicherstellen und
das ist ein ganz wesentlicher Schritt
was für eine putzbeher Merz schön dass
sie jetzt auch da sind sie kritisieren
die Gaslieferung aus Katar hätten wir
Ihrem Vorschlag im März gefolgt ein
gasembargo auszusprechen während wir
jetzt in einer katastrophalen
gasmangelage sie hätten das Land an die
Wand gefahren
und da wir das Thema
Versorgungssicherheit so gut wie möglich
jetzt geregelt haben machen wir heute
den Aufschlag um den zweiten wichtigen
Punkt zur Bewältigung dieser Krise zu
bewerkstelligen nämlich das Thema
Bezahlbarkeit und auch ja Andreas Jung
da sind wir selbstbewusste
Parlamentarier wir gucken uns jetzt
diesen Gesetzesentwurf einschließlich
der Bremsen und der damit verbundenen
Problematiken an aber was man hier sagen
muss ist das was sie hier gemacht haben
als es um die Finanzierungsfrage dieser
Bremse geht sie haben nicht zugestimmt
ohne ihn hätten wir ohne sie hätten wir
mit ihnen hätten wir überhaupt gar kein
Geld diese Bremsen jetzt zu organisieren
sie waren gegen die 200 Milliarden
deswegen kann ich nur sagen es war für
unsere Fraktion sehr sehr wichtig dass
wir neben dem 100 Milliarden
entlastungspaketen jetzt einen
systemischen Eingriff in die
Preisbildung vonnehmen und damit
schaffen wir Sicherheit für Verbrauchern
und Verbraucher und für weite Teile der
Wirtschaft aber zur Wahrheit gehört auch
wir Bremsen auf das Niveau so dass das
Doppelte im Vergleich zum
vorkriegszeitraum immer noch zu stemmen
ist insofern ist das Thema
Einsparung von Energie nach wie vor eins
was uns alle angeht
aber das zentrale ist dass wir ein
System haben was nun kalkulierbar für
die Zeit bis April 24 ist klar ist und
ich weiß dass Dietmar Bartsch mit
Sicherheit auch darauf hinweisen wird es
wird keine Einzelfallgerechtigkeit bei
einem solchen Gesetz geben aber der
Anspruch ist schon dass wir versuchen so
gut wie möglich und so zielgenau wie
möglich dieses Gesetz zu formulieren und
deswegen
und deswegen will ich hier ein paar
Punkte benennen ja
augenblicklich und das war zentrale
Aufgabe der Kommission richten wir uns
an gastkunden aber wir wissen dass es
auch Härten im Bereich von ölpellets und
Flüssigkeits gibt insofern wollen wir
uns auch eine Regelung für diese
Abfederung ausdenken und sie kreieren
das wird die Aufgabe der nächsten 14
Tage für die Parlamentarier in diesem
Raum sein
der zweite wichtige Punkt ist die
Versorger haben in der Kommission der
sehr deutlich gemacht dass sie nicht
wissen wer sich hinter einem Anschluss
verbirgt das ist die große
Herausforderung so zielgenau wie möglich
zu sein und deswegen nehmen wir uns vor
auch bis April 24 zu überlegen welche
Daten brauchen wir um dann zielgenau im
Zweifel zu steuern und auch zu
unterstützen und wenn wir es jetzt nicht
ganz schnell schaffen für diesen Winter
dann ist mindestens der Herbst und der
Winter 23 24 dann der Zeitpunkt wo wir
noch zielgenauer noch gerechter noch
besser werden liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und zudem geht es ja Andreas Jung aber
das nun gerade ausgerechnet die cdu/csu
die Erneuerbaren entdeckt hat okay man
lernt dazu aber es geht natürlich darum
dass wir hier nicht Investitionen
abwürgen im Bereich der erneuerbaren und
deswegen ist das Thema Biogas ein Thema
was wir uns in den nächsten zwei Wochen
auch noch mal vornehmen werden um hier
keine Fehlsteuerung zu produzieren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
für diese Koalition ist somit
entscheidend dass wir Krise bewältigen
Versorgungssicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
sicherstellen aber den dritten Punkt den
dürfen wir nicht vernachlässigen und wir
vernachlässigen in auch nicht in dieser
Krise muss das neue gleichzeitig massiv
zum Durchbruch verholfen werden und
insofern ist der massive Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien der Punkt den wir
genauso auf diese Tagesordnung setzen
dann wird die Krise bewältigen mit einer
zukunftsrichtung darauf kommt es an
vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
und dies für die Koalition der
stellvertierende Fraktionsvorsitzende
Matthias Mirsch nächster Redner Steffen
cotré
afd-fraktion das ganze hier in
beschleunigten Verfahren dieses
Gesetzesvorhaben für die Bremsen das ist
ehrgeizig noch vor dem
parlamentarischen Winterpause
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
liebe Besucher liebe Zuschauer im Land
Frau Dr Nestle hamirsch ich muss einfach
mal ein bisschen Wasser in den
propagandistischen Wein gießen heute
morgen hatten wir
Gigawatt Leistung und zwar von den
fossilen und lediglich 5 Gigawatt die
aus erneuerbaren Quellen standen und so
viel zum Thema die Erneuerbaren könnten
hier unser Land also mit Strom
Versorgung übrigens von den 61 waren 20
GB Gas und so viel auch zum Thema dass
man die Kernkraftwerke nicht anstellen
möchte
die Gesetze zu den Preis Bremsen sind
eine Volksverdummung wie wir sie seit
Erich Honecker nicht mehr hatten die
Ampelkoalition zerstört erst die Gas und
Stromversorgung macht Strom und Gas so
teuer wie nie und wie sonst nirgends
dann steht sie uns 200 Milliarden
Finanzierung aus den Steuergeldern um
den Brand einzudämmen den sie selbst
gelegt hat aber liebe
liebe Zuschauer lassen sich da nicht an
der Nase herumführen die 200 Milliarden
Euro könnten für Soziales für Schulen
für Zukunftstechnologie ausgegeben
werden aber mit dieser Ampel Koalition
haben wir ein Abrissunternehmen und mit
dieser Regierung haben wir in der links
grüne trümmertruppe die Deutschland
Schritt für Schritt leider abschafft
meine Damen und Herren
und mal zum Vergleich in der Schweiz
liegt der Strompreis
2023 bei 25 Cent bei uns beträgt der 45
bis 60 Cent also das Doppelte die
Inflationsrate beträgt 3,5 Prozent bei
uns mit zehn Prozent das Dreifache woran
liegt das die Schweiz hat eine Regierung
die der Bevölkerung verpflichtet ist im
übrigen haben sie auch direkte
Demokratie wir haben eine Regierung die
die die der USA China dem
Internationalen Währungsfonds der EU
Marokko oder anderen verpflichtet ist
die USA und China bekommen gerade von
uns ganze Industriezweige geschenkt weil
deutsche Unternehmen zu preiswerten
energiestandorten Wechseln der IWF
bekommt zig Milliarden für sinnlose
klimamaßnahmen um diese dann in der
ganzen Welt zu verteilen in der EU
zahlen wir für green Deal und die
Wirtschafts- und
gesellschaftstransformation die uns
Planwirtschaft und Bevormundung beschert
in Marokko wird gerade das Finanzsystem
reformiert und wir Steuerzahler dürfen
uns an deren Kosten beteiligen
Vaterlands liebe meine Damen und Herren
Vaterlands Liebe findet augenscheinlich
nun die gesamte
Ampelkoalition zum kotzen und den
Ministern ist es egal was die Wähler
denken
bis 2060 werden wir und unsere
Nachkommen den infantilen doppelwumms
also den doppelt dummen Wumms wenn man
so will noch bezahlen müssen die
Verpflichtung Deutschlands mit jetzt
schon mehr als 14 Billionen Euro sind
ohnehin nicht mehr ohne
entschädigungslose Enteignungen durch
Inflation oder
diebstahlrückzahlbar wir drohen Zustände
zu bekommen wie ein Diktaturen also wo
Stabilität Eigentum Freiheit
wirtschaftliche enthaltungsmöglichkeiten
nichts mehr zählen meine Damen und
Herren und ab jetzt ausgehandelten
gasziel mit Katar lässt sich das Ganze
versagen und die ganze
veruntreuungspolitik der links grünen
trümmertruppe festmachen obwohl sich
abwicklungs ab Wirtschaftsminister habe
vor dem Scheiß was auf dem Boden
geworfen hat werden wir nur magere 2%
unserer Versorgungslücke damit schließen
können und dass er auch erst ab 2026
russisches Gas verweigern aber keine
Alternative haben also das ist das
Niveau meines zweijährigen Sohnes der
also sein Nuckel wegschweißt und sich
dann wundert dass er nicht mehr nuckeln
kann
Weg hören Chaos überall die Erstattung
der vermiedenen Netzentgelte wird
abgeschafft aber mit dieser abstattung
kalkulierten kleinere dezentrale
Stromerzeuger die Stadtwerke zum
Beispiel die nun ein Teil ihrer
Investition nicht mehr abdecken können
mit dieser
unvorhergesehenen Streichung nimmt man
natürlich auch ein Stück
Rechtssicherheit hier in Deutschland weg
und ja wie lange wird dieses
zusammengeschusterte Konglomerat an
Regelungen halten bevor es also das
Bundesverfassungsgericht wieder kassiert
wenn das dann so kommt dann stehen
unsere Menschen hier im Land leider im
Regen und die soziale Schieflage ist
vorprogrammiert meine Damen und Herren
nein die Lösung ist ganz einfach
Ausdehnung des künstlich verknappten
Angebotes und damit Senkung der Preise
das spart Geld anstatt es den
Steuerzahlern wegzunehmen alle Kohle und
Kernkraftwerke ans Netz Nord Stream 2
muss für Gas Importe geöffnet werden
ganz einfach meine Damen und Herren die
Ampelkoalition die ist ein
Abrissunternehmen und Deutschland leider
das Opfer aber das wird den Menschen
nicht lange verborgen bleiben nach
Abwicklung der links grüne Politik meine
Damen und Herren nach Beendigung der
Politik der verbrannten Erde bauen wird
Deutschland wieder auf
[Applaus]
meine Damen und Herren soweit der
Redebeitrag von Steffen coutrey er sitzt
für die AFD im Ausschuss für Klimaschutz
und Energie es war sozusagen eine
frontale Breitseite gegen alles was hier
vorgebracht wurde aber gegen Vorschläge
war nicht in dieser Rede Lukas Köhler
jetzt stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzender der FDP
Bundestagsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren
lieber Kollege sie sind ja eingestiegen
in ihre Debatte gerade in ihrer Rede
dass wir zu viel Kohle im Netz haben und
ausgestiegen sie sind wie dass wir nicht
genug Kohle im Netz haben ich glaube das
einzige was sie sich mit ihrer Rede
gerade verdient haben ist das
fleißbienchen aus Moskau aber sonst gar
nicht tut mir leid
es tut mir leid dass Sie gerade
aufgezählt haben ist doch absurd ja es
ist richtig wir haben gerade sehr viel
mehr Kohle im im Stromsystem warum damit
wir für eine ausreichende
Versorgungssicherheit sorgen natürlich
argumentieren und gehen wir davon aus
dass wir in jeder Zeit zu jeder Stunde
an jedem Tag ausreichend Strom brauchen
und deswegen ist dieser energiekrieg den
Putin gegen Deutschland und Europa führt
das was uns zu all den Maßnahmen die wir
jetzt angehen zwingt es soll nicht weil
wir denken Mensch super lass uns mehr
Kohle aus der Reserve holen oder lass
uns insgesamt 300 Milliarden an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger dieses Landes
geben damit sie mit den Preisen klar
kommen die dadurch entstehen sind wir
sind gezwungen zu diesen Maßnahmen wir
sind gezwungen dazu das zu tun was wir
gerade umsetzen und zwar weil es einen
Krieg in der Ukraine gibt und weil es
ein Krieg gegen dieses Land durch
Vladimir Putin auf der Energie und
Wirtschaftsseite gibt und ja wir helfen
den Ukraine und ja die Ukraine wird
gewinnen und ja wir werden durch diesen
Winter kommen
dadurch dass wir den Menschen helfen
dass wir der Industrie dass wir der
Wirtschaft helfen dass wir dafür sorgen
dass Gas und Kohle günstig genug bleibt
Kollege gestatten sie eine Zwischenfrage
oder Zwischenbemerkung von Herrn Vahle
nein danke nein
wir haben uns auf der Angebotsseite
vorgenommen gehabt dafür zu sorgen dass
das da ist was nötig ist die Speicher
sind voll die Kohlekraftwerke gehen
wieder ins Netz die Kernkraftwerke
laufen bis in den April und versorgen
uns mit ausreichend Strom wir müssen
aber natürlich auch an die preisseite
denken und ja es gibt eine Menge Herten
und deswegen ist es richtig dass wir uns
dafür entschieden haben einen oder zwei
Instrumente zu wählen die einfach
wirksam und unbürokratisch sind und ja
damit kann man nicht immer zielgenau
sein ja da gibt es Probleme und Fehler
aber ja was auch richtig ist und da bin
ich Robert Habeck dafür sehr dankbar
dass er diesen Vorschlag hier vorliegt
zur strompreisbremse zur gaspreisbremse
weil es ist richtig und es ist wichtig
dass wir diese Maßnahmen jetzt einführen
dass die Menschen unterstützt werden
dass die Unternehmen dass sie Industrie
weiterlaufen kann dass die ökonomische
Fähigkeit dieses Landes erhalten wird
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir diese
Maßnahmen und trotzdem bringen sie die
sparenreize die wir brauchen denn wir
müssen über diesen Winter kommen und wir
müssen für den nächsten dahinter
vorbereitet sein und trotzdem ist es gut
und richtig dass wir ein Instrument
gefunden haben mit der gaspreisbremse
dass die Kosten so senkt dass wir
vorwärts
und es ist auch wichtig dass wir uns bei
der strompreisbremse sehr intensiv jetzt
auch im parlamentarischen Verfahren noch
mal angucken was da passiert das bmwk
hat einen Vorschlag vorgelegt mit dem
man sehr gut arbeiten kann ich glaube es
gibt eine Reihe von technischen Fragen
die wir klären müssen sowohl auf der
Seite des auszahlungsmechanismus aber
vor allen Dingen auf Seite der Art des
abschöpfungsmechanismus es ist klar dass
das ein ganz neues Instrument ist und
neue Instrumente sind in der Politik
fehleranfällig natürlich das ist ganz
normal es gibt Probleme und
Herausforderungen insbesondere wenn wir
Dinge sehr schnell sehr zielgerichtet
machen müssen und ja wir müssen darüber
nachdenken dass wir zum Beispiel neue
Anlagen von der Abschöpfung ausnehmen
weil wir dürfen mit der Preis Bremse
keine Investitionsbremse schaffen wir
dürfen nicht dafür sorgen dass in neue
Technologien in neue Anlagen nicht im
nächsten Jahr investiert wird und
deswegen glaube ich dass wir da viel
machen müssen und ja auch im Bereich der
Bioenergie kann man noch einiges machen
aber man muss auch dazu sagen wir haben
die europäische Ebene die zwingt uns
dazu eine ganze Reihe von Dingen zu tun
und deswegen müssen wir und können wir
dafür sorgen dass wir an den richtigen
Stellen Entlastung schaffen aber wir
brauchen natürlich auch die Einnahmen
und das gewährt diese Abschöpfung dieses
Instrument das gewährt uns die
Möglichkeit gezielt zu handeln die
Preise zu senken und dafür zu sorgen
dass an der richtigen Stelle das
richtige Geld ankommt wir werden im
parlamentarischen vertragen Verfahren
dieses Gesetz noch besser machen wir
werden die technischen Fragen klären wir
werden dafür sorgen dass richtige
Investitionsanreiz an der richtigen
Stelle sind ich freue mich auf die
weiteren Verhandlungen vielen Dank
Lukas Köhler hat das angerissen es ist
noch einiges zu tun in diesen nächsten
zwei Wochen wenn das alles so gut
gelingen kann dann könnte zum 16
Dezember im Bundesrat das ganze
abschließend über die Bühne gehen im
parlamentarischen Verfahren
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin
ich will den Vorredner nur mal sagen die
müsste doch bekannt sein das vor sechs
Jahren Herr Habeck gefordert hat
keinerlei Gas mehr und Rohstoffe aus
Russland zu holen dafür gibt es Videos
die seine Äußerungen aufgezeichnet haben
jetzt müssten sie doch glücklich sein
weil er habe geschafft hat was erreicht
hat und dann faseln sie etwas davon das
Putin Gas als Druckmittel nutzt sondern
ihre grünen Link Vorstellung sind halt
linkes falsch aber ihre grünen falschen
Vorstellungen sind doch alle ja die sind
doch die FDP von heute ist doch nichts
anderes als der Wurmfortsatz dieser
grünen Partei und dann fahren Sie hier
etwas von dem Krieg von Moskau der hier
unser Gast erreicht es werden doch ihre
Träume verwirklicht die verschleudern
das Geld der Menschen und damit komme
ich auch schon zum Schluss erzählen sie
den Leuten doch nicht so ein Unsinn
diese Krise die wir in der
Energiepolitik haben haben sie als
Ampelkoalition selbst herbeigeführt
vielen Dank
soweit die Kurzintervention Robert fahle
war mein Mitglied der afd-fraktion und
ist jetzt fraktionslos möchte Lukas
Köhler entgegnen ja möchte
mehr brauche ich dazu nicht zu sagen
das war umfassende nächste Redner hat
sich auch bereits bereit gemacht das ist
Dietmar Bartsch der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linken mal schauen ob Bärbel Bass
das noch mal aufnimmt
jetzt kann ich aber den nächsten Redner
aufrufen für die Fraktion DIE LINKE dr
Dietmar Bartsch
Mikroanlage plus Herr köhlerischen
ziemlich genial ja Frau Präsident meine
Damen und Herren Freunde sie haben hier
gesprochen von grandios und Umsetzungen
so kurzer Zeit ehrlich gesagt das kann
ich so ganz nachvollziehen also noch im
Sommer hat diese Regierung eine
gasumlage angekündigt während andere
Länder in Europa schon lange die
Energiepreise gedeckelt haben und sich
auf den Winter vorbereitet haben haben
sie noch über höhere Preise spartorniert
das ist doch die Wahrheit deswegen muss
ich ja habe doch die Frage gefallen
lassen warum erst jetzt warum reden wir
heute das erste Mal über dieses Thema
nach Monaten 9 Monaten nach Beginn des
fürchterlichen Krieges die Wahrheit ist
doch spät später habe ich so wie sie
heute zu spät gekommen sind das ist die
Wahrheit meine Damen und Herren beide
beide
Strom und gaspreisbremse hätten lange da
sein müssen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen in Deutschland zahlen
letztlich für ihre zu spät Politik
einhören Preis ja natürlich ist doch
völlig unbestritten das Gas
strompreisbremsen geeignete Maßnahmen
sind die explodierenden Energiepreise
einzudämmen und ist auch richtig dort
ist das dort entsprechende mittelbreit
gestellt wird völlig unstrittig aber es
ist eben nicht nur viel später es ist
auch noch mangelhaft ihre bremsen würde
kein TÜV in Deutschland anerkennen meine
Damen und Herren weil
erstens sind die Bremsen zu hoch
zweitens sind sie eine Einladung zum
Abkassieren drittens sind sie sozial
zutiefst ungerecht und viertens sind sie
Schmieröl für die Gewinne der
Energiekonzerne mit dem ersten Beginn 40
Cent pro Kilowattstunde beim Strom die
sind natürlich deutlich zu hoch das ist
im Moment erstmal überhaupt keine Bremse
sondern aktuell ist das ein Gaspedal
zumindest bei den strombremsen beim
Strompreisen gebremst gebremst wurde
realen in Österreich da sind das 10 Cent
pro haushaltskontingen das wäre eine
Bremse 10 Cent meine Damen und Herren
wenn die strompreisbremse bei 40 Cent
ansetzt dann ist das doch logisch dass
kein Versorger darunter bleibt warum
warum kontrollieren sie dann nicht die
Preise wenn sie bei 40 Cent die Rechnung
übernehmen müssen sie doch sich von den
Versorgern erklären lassen wieso der
eine 53% und der andere vielleicht 66
Prozent nimmt das kann doch nicht wahr
sein ohne staatliche Preiskontrollen
sind Strom und gaspreisbremsen eine
Einladung zum Abkassieren meine Damen
und Herren das ist die Wahrheit und
lieber Matthias Mirsch zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen das Hauptproblem ist die
soziale Ungerechtigkeit wir alle hier
und alle anderen gut Verdiener
profitieren doch von den Bremsen am
meisten das ist doch die Wahrheit mehr
als die Bevölkerung ansonsten es kann
doch nicht wahr sein ich will den
Wirtschaftsminister zitieren er hat
gesagt gerecht wäre dass sie besonders
bedürftig sind besonders viel bekommen
aber das Gegenteil ist doch der Fall wer
in diesem Jahr werden in diesem Jahr
gespart hat oder sparen musste weil er
gar nicht anders konnte der bekommt so
gut wie gar nichts
je höher der Verbrauch desto gehören die
Entlastung das ist doch die Wahrheit und
das bedeutet wenn eine Villa hat und wer
jetzt vielleicht im spätherz noch ein
paar Bahnen im Außenpool schwimmt der
bekommt eben viel viel mehr das ist
sozialpolitischer Wahnsinn ihre Gas und
strompreisbremse ist Umverteilung von
unten nach oben er ist ein Katalysator
für soziale Ungerechtigkeit das ist die
Wahrheit meine Damen und manche können
nicht mehr sparen manche können einfach
nicht mehr schlafen und wir haben ja
Alternativen vorgeschlagen mit den
bürgerkontingen ich muss das jetzt alles
sehr abkürzen weil ich noch eine
Bemerkung zu den Energiekonzern machen
will ich meine sie haben angekündigt die
Gewinne abzuschaffen ja Investitionen
schützen das ist alles unbestritten aber
ehrlich gesagt auch da kommt doch viel
viel weniger auf einmal jetzt erst ab
Dezember das war doch mal anders
vorgesehen 50 Milliarden Euro allein den
Stromkunden wurde in diesem Jahr aus der
Tasche gezogen warum wird das ständig
wieder zurück um verteilt holen Sie sich
das Geld zurück bei der Ampel läuft
real,-
wer hat Angst vor Christian Lindner das
ist ist die Wahrheit das ist die
Wahrheit wer hat Angst vor Christian
Lindner das machen sie sie immer wenn
dort blockiert wird haben sie keinen Mut
mehr deswegen reparieren sie ihre
Bremsen nehmen Sie unsere Vorschläge auf
niedrige Deckel festes Kontingent
Preiskontrollen und eine ordentliche
übergewinnsteuer meine Damen und Herren
herzlichen Dank
Dietmar Barsch der Fraktionsvorsitzende
der Linken im Deutschen Bundestag hier
auch noch mal mit einem play Dua je für
das Gerechtigkeitsprinzip innerhalb der
Bremsen und eine deutliche Nachbesserung
im parlamentarischen Prozess
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin am 21
oktober haben SPD Grüne und FDP hier
gemeinsam dem Abwehrschirm von 200
Milliarden Euro Gaspreis
strompreisbremse beschlossen wer Herr
Merz wäre jung hat dagegen gestimmt es
war die Union in den Haushaltsberatungen
haben sie keine Alternativen
Finanzierungsvorschläge unterbracht sie
sind kein verlässlicher Partner für die
Unternehmen und die Menschen in
Landwasser Sicherheit angeht sie haben
dieser historischen Situation versagt
die preisbremsen sind das richtige
wirtschaftspolitische Instrument um den
energieangriff von Russland abzuwehren
Militär und auch Wirtschaftshilfen
Richtung Ukraine sind das richtige
Instrument um dort zu helfen dass die
Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen kann und
Russland diesen Krieg verliert auch das
ist in unserem Interesse
Unternehmen bekommen mit diesen Preis
Bremsen schnell und unbürokratisch
finanzielle Unterstützung es sind keine
Anträge nötig die Energieversorger
reduzieren direkt die Rechnung
ganz wichtig wir behalten die
energieeinsparanreize bei und zwar ab
der ersten Kilowattstunde die
preisbremsen sind klug konzipiert die
finanzielle Unterstützung erfolgt als
eine Art Gutschrift die praktisch
unabhängig vom Verbrauch ist und deshalb
gilt weiterhin einsparen lohnt sich das
ist auch sehr wichtig dass eingespart
wird nicht nur für die
Versorgungssicherheit in diesem Land
sondern auch dass wir die Preise runter
kriegen das geht nur indem wir mehr
einsparen auch in diesem Winter und auch
im kommenden Wind
ganz wichtig wir schaffen jetzt Planungs
und Investitionssicherheit das ist
wichtig für den Bäcker in München Pasing
oder die BürgerInnen in Traunstein die
auf eine Wärmepumpe jetzt installieren
will ganz wichtig aber auch im kommenden
Jahr werden wir massiv in den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien investieren und
diesen forstieren Energieeffizienz
Einsparung dort auf uns konzentrieren
heute morgen hatte ich eine Runde mit
Kolleginnen zum Inflation redakt der
Amerikaner dort ist ein
Investitionsprogramm im Rahmen von Open
End im Prinzip 800 Milliarden Euro
vorgesehen das heißt das race to the top
das beginnt jetzt erst weltweit wer am
stärksten ist im Haus bei der Neubauern
Energie der stärkt auch die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit in Deutschland und
darum geht es jetzt ganz zentral
zu den Rahmenbedingungen in der Energie
und Gas und strompreisbremse der
Weiterverkauf von Gas bleibt möglich und
das ist auch wichtig für Wirtschaften
ArbeitnehmerInnen denn so schaffen wir
die höchsten Effizienzen wir haben eine
arbeitsplatzerhaltungspflicht hier
verankert im Gesetzentwurf das werden
wir nochmal in der Ausgestaltung prüfen
es ist wichtig dass auch die Menschen
darauf vertrauen können wenn Unternehmen
profitieren bleiben Arbeitsplätze
erhalten
wichtig ist auch keiner soll übermäßig
von den Bremsen profitieren deswegen
Stellen Höchstgrenzen sicher dass nur
Unternehmen die Hilfen erhalten die sie
dann auch wirklich benötigen die
besonders hart getroffen sind und diese
Bremsen müssen auch europäisch
abgestimmt sein das heißt die
europäischen Partner dürfen wir nicht
vergessen wir haben volle Gasspeicher
das ist gut aber die sind auch in einem
europäischen Verbund das heißt
europäisch zu handeln auch darauf wird
es zentral ankommenden kommenden
Wochenden Monaten wir handeln jetzt hier
sehr entschlossen schaffen Sicherheit
helfen den Unternehmen und im nächsten
Jahr kommt das Jahr wo wir dann die
Wettbewerbsbedingungen auch für die
Industrie für die Wirtschaft zentral
voranbringen werden mit erneuerbaren
Energien Energieeffizienz darauf kommt
es jetzt an ich danke Ihnen
wir hatten gerade an Pult für die
Koalition Dieter Janecek von der Bündnis
90 grünen Fraktion also alles was jetzt
noch nicht passgenau ist so hat er
versprochen wird hier noch nachgebessert
nächster Redner jetzt hier angekündigt
für uns Fraktion Lars Gruber
[Applaus]
denn in meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren seit vielen Monaten Wissen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger das schwierige
Zeiten auf Sie zukommen und dass sie
gerade wenn sie mit kleinen und
mittleren Einkommen ausgestattet sind
vor großen finanziellen
Herausforderungen steht aber die
Bundesregierung blieb aus unserer Sicht
viel zu lange untätig es brauchte
mehrere entlastungspakete um alle
Hilfsbedürftigen Bevölkerungsgruppen zu
erkennen auf der Suche nach vergessenen
Bevölkerungsgruppen das später die
Bundesregierung in ihrem Elfenbeinturm
am 4 september die Studierenden und
Rentner durch ihr Fernrohr und kündigte
eine Einmalzahlung über 200 Euro an es
brauchte zwei Monate
bis das Kabinett das beschlossen hat und
es wird zwei Monate dauern bis diese
Regelung in Kraft tritt es wird aber
weitere Monate brauchen bis dieses Geld
auch bei den Betroffenen und Studenten
ankommt weil sie gar keine digitale
Plattform haben
damit wir uns nicht falsch verstehen wir
begrüßen die 200 Euro sehr aber es
fehlte bei den Studis immer irgendwas
erstmal ist die energiepreispauschale
die es nur mit Minijob gibt
Heizkostenzuschuss nur zehn Prozent 9
Euro Ticket durcheinander bis hin zu den
Mensa Gutscheinen sie haben einfach drei
Monate vertütet
und dann
dann ist das Gesetz auch nicht
vollständig gestern in der
regierungsbefragung kam raus die
Meisterschüler haben sie vergessen
das Gesetz ist also an dieser Stelle
absolut unverständlich wir denken aber
auch dass das Gesetz unnötig ist denn
sie wollen mit diesem Gesetz nur die
Verantwortung an die Länder
transportieren dass wenn das Geld dann
nicht rechtzeitig ankommt sie es den
Ländern in die Schuhe schieben können
deshalb beantragen wir häufig hier im
Plenum das endlich Schluss mit dem
verhandeln ist und dass der Bund selbst
die Plattform baut und zwar in den
nächsten 14 Tagen sie aber werden
wahrscheinlich weiter vorstellen sie
werden uns nicht wir werden uns nicht
gegen die Studierenden stellen aber wir
wollen dass hier Schluss ist mit diesen
Regelungen mit ihrem Gesetzentwurf
lassen Sie einen leistungsgesetz mit
einer Verordnungsermächtigung zur
späteren Festlegung des konkreten
Verfahrens dieses Vorgehen ist aus
unserer Sicht völlig planlos und
entbehrt jeder föderalen Zusammenarbeit
und auch gestern in der
Regierungserklärung
regierungsbefragung wenig konkret ist
redes wenig abbrechenbares Frau
Ministerin stark Watzinger bei Antworten
auf unsere konkreten Fragen verlieren
sie sich im Ungefähren klein das war
viel wir wollen wir machen wir werden
aber ganz wenig um nicht zu sagen viel
zu wenig wir machen wir tun Frau stark
Watzinger sie bezeichnen ihr Ministerium
selbst als chancenministerium ich möchte
Sie bitten dass sie nicht weiter die
Ministerin der vertanen Chancen sind
vielen Dank für die Aufmerksamkeit
von Lars Rover hier noch mal der
spezielle Hinweis den wir auch schon im
Interview festgestellt haben es gibt die
hier noch einen eine gewisse bringe
Pflicht durch die Bundesregierung auch
für alle die die Hilfe für Auszubildende
und Studierende beantragen wollen die
digitale Plattform wirklich arbeitsfähig
zu machen jetzt Andreas medretter für
die SPD-Fraktion wir sind immer noch in
der Krise und trotzdem hat sich das
Konjunkturbarometer des Deutschen
Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung im
November erholt die Gründe sind so dass
die wie die Sicherstellung der
Gasversorgung und die bisherigen und die
geplanten entlastungspakete der Ampel
unsere Politik wird
das zeigt das Konjunkturbarometer es
zeigt aber auch dass wir noch weit weg
vom Normalzustand sind steigende Preise
labile Lieferketten und die weiterhin
unsichere Lage belasten Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und die Wirtschaft sie brauchen
weiterhin Unterstützung deswegen bringen
wir heute die preisbremsen für Gas Wärme
und Strom in den Bundestag ein weil wir
als Ampel genau für diese Unterstützung
sorgen
meine Damen und Herren es ist zu Beginn
der parlamentarischen Beratungen
hilfreich noch mal ein Schritt
zurückzutreten und sich den
Abschlussbericht der expert in den
Kommission anzuschauen dieser Bericht
enthält eben nicht nur einzelne
Maßnahmen er ein enthält ein ökonomisch
ziemlich schlaues Gesamtkonzept das Ziel
sind schnelle Entlastungen und ein
wirksamer Schutz vor Überforderung aber
es geht natürlich auch darum die
Volkswirtschaft und die Preise zu
stabilisieren und es geht darum weitere
ein paar Anreize zu setzen es ist schlau
dort anzusetzen wo die Ursache für die
jetzige Situation liegt es sind die
steigenden Gas und Strompreise die die
Inflation ausgelöst haben es sind die
Liquidität der Betriebe und den
Kaufkraft bis in die Mittelschicht
hinein auffressen und genau dagegen
helfen die preisbremsen
es ist auch schlau dass wir die vollen
Anreize zum Einsparen mit dem Bremsen
erhalten wie Kollege janicek gerade
schon gesagt hat richtet sich die
Entlastung nach dem prognostizierten
Verbrauch und ist eben entsprechend fix
wer Geld wer Gas und Strom spart spart
sich mit jeder Kilowattstunde bares Geld
und es ist schlau dass wir mit die dass
wir uns das Geld dort wieder zurückholen
wo mit der aktuellen Energiekrise große
Gewinne gemacht werden wir beschließen
morgen übergewinne der Mineralölkonzerne
zu extra zu besteuern und wir schöpfen
unerwartet hohe Erlöse von Strom
erzeugen ab so geht solidarische Politik
in Krisenzeiten meine Damen und Herren
gerade die erlös-abschöpfung im
Strommarkt ist eine hochkomplexe
Angelegenheit wir greifen damit tief in
den Markt ein aber so zielgerichtet dass
wir keinerlei zusätzlichen Anreiz für
die Verstromung von Gas geben das wollen
wir nicht das müssen wir vermeiden um
Gas einzusparen
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich noch
wichtige Punkte die wir prüfen müssen
dazu gehört die Frage wie die
Auswirkungen der Abschöpfung am
Strommarkt auf die auf den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energie aus es ist richtig
zumindest einen Teil der Preis Bremsen
aus den übergewinnen der Energieerzeuger
zu finanzieren wir brauchen aber auch
mehr Tempo und Planungssicherheit beim
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren Investitionen in
erneuerbare müssen weiterhin attraktiv
bleiben auch das müssen und werden wir
sicherstellen
meine Damen und Herren um zwei
Prozentpunkte können wir die Inflation
durch die Preisbremse senken sagen
Ökonomen von Deutsche Bank research
genau das brauchen die Menschen und die
Unternehmen in unserem Land ich betone
das auch noch mal ganz bewusst mit Blick
auf Sie meine Damen und Herren von der
Union ihr Fraktionsvorsitzender hat ja
bereits angekündigt die preisbremsen im
Bundesrat aufhalten zu wollen sie wollen
die Entlastungen verzögern auf die die
Menschen dringend warten soll das
verantwortungsvolle Opposition sein ich
glaube nicht wir machen
verantwortungsvolle Regierungsarbeit wir
sorgen mit den Preis Bremsen für die
notwendige Entlastung in dieser
schwierigen Zeit so geht schlaue und
solidarische Politik vielen Dank
die erste Lesung weiterhin der
energiepreisbremsen durch die
Bundesregierung Gesetzentwürfe
eingebracht jetzt geht es Frömming
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
afd-fraktion Frau Präsidentin Werte
Kollegen also ich finde es ehrlich
gesagt unerträglich wie sich die Ampel
hier heute selbst lobt wofür denn
eigentlich für das herumpfuschen an den
Symptomen einer Krankheit die sie doch
selbst mit ihrer Politik erst
herbeigeführt haben meine Damen und
Herren
und lass mich in diesem Zusammenhang
noch ein Wort sagen zu dem hier ja mit
debattierten Vorschlag eine
energiepauschale für Studenten
auszuzahlen das sind der Tat auch
notwendig denn mehr als ein Drittel der
Studenten sind armutsgefährdet viele
haben die Temperaturen in ihren
Wohnungen herabgesenkt auf 16 Grad im
Durchschnitt und da finde ich schon
ehrlich gesagt zynisch wenn eine
Abgeordnete der Grünen auf Twitter sich
beklagt dass es hier im Bundestag doch
zu kalt sei und sie müssen einen Schal
anziehen und heißen Tee trinken meine
Damen und Herren wenn einer kein Recht
hat sich über Temperaturen zu beklagen
dann sind es die Grünen
vielleicht auch noch ein Wort zu den
Anträgen der Union also liebe Kollegen
das ist ja schon ein kleines Kuckucksei
was sie hier der Ampel ins Nest legen
wollen sie schlagen vor dass das
Bundesministerium und jetzt weniger die
Länder dafür zuständig sein sollten die
200 Euro möglichst schnell auszuzahlen
glauben Sie das eigentlich im Ernst dass
das das Bundesministerium hinbekommt in
der notwendigen Zeit ich erinnere nur
mal daran wie lange wir auf den
digitalpakt gewartet haben 2019
beschlossen und immer noch warten viele
Schulen darauf dass die simpelsten
Einrichtungen wie ein Breitbandanschluss
oder funktionierende Laptops ankommen
auch da schon hat der Bund versagt der
Bund versagt in zentralen Dingen deshalb
wäre es wesentlich besser und
zielführender sie würden für eine
vernünftige Politik sorgen die Energie
bezahlbar macht und überlassen ansonsten
denen etwas die was davon verstehen
nämlich den Ländern vor Ort die können
die Unternehmer an den Schulen selbst
dann viel besser beheben ich danke Ihnen
meine Damen und Herren
tatsächlich wir erwarten wir jetzt die
erste ministeräußerung in dieser Debatte
es war schon von ihr die Rede dass sie
ihre Chancen besser nutzen soll Bettina
stark Watzinger die Bundesministerin für
Bildung und Forschung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier geht es
heute um mehr als ein Grad Celsius in
Räumen hier geht es heute mehr als auch
nur um das Geld wir schützen heute
unsere Zukunftschancen davon haben wir
zusammen gekämpft und zwar erfolgreich
dafür dass Forschung und Wissenschaft
einbezogen sind bei den Entlastungen
dass die gut durch die Energiekrise
kommen nehmen wir die
Teilchenbeschleuniger an den
helmholzinstituten die strahlzeiten ist
ein Monate voraus ausgebucht ohne strieb
ohne Strom aber keinen Betrieb keine
Forschung und im Worst Case bleiben
hunderte qualifizierungsarbeiten auf der
Strecke tausende Erkenntnisse oder in
einer Biobank wenn die
abluftfiltersysteme bei den
Krankheitserregern nicht mehr betrieben
werden können
jahrelange Arbeit umsonst wir setzen uns
heute für Wissenschaft und Forschung ein
damit wir morgen überhaupt noch die
Basis für Wissenschaft Forschung haben
meine Damen und Herren
und wir entlasten dreifach
alle wissenschaftlichen Einrichtungen
egal wie groß erhalten die Dezember
Soforthilfe außerdem greift die
gassenstrombremse für Kitas Schulen
Hochschulen und die großen
Forschungseinrichtungen und ein
härtefallfonds bringt die
energieintensive Forschung durch die
Krise die großen Anlagen die viel Strom
brauchen vom Teilchenbeschleuniger bis
zum höchstleistungsrechner damit ist die
außeruniversitäre Forschung abgedeckt
dank härtefallfonds damit erhalten wir
die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit unseres
Wissenschaftssystems
unsere Reaktionsfähigkeit gestatten sie
eine Zwischenfrage oder
Zwischenbemerkung
[Musik]
unsere re Handlungsfähigkeit auf Krisen
der Klimawandel macht ja keine Pause nur
weil wir gerade ein Energieproblem haben
unsere Wettbewerber halten nicht inne
nur weil unsere Versorgung mit Gas und
Öl wie sie neue Regeln müssen wenn wir
weiter gut leben wollen dann müssen
Wissenschaft und Forschung
weiterarbeiten können auch in der Krise
meine Damen und Herren
mit
bis zu 2 Milliarden Euro unterstützen
wir die Bildungs- und
Forschungseinrichtungen damit leistet
der Bund einen großen Beitrag in
schwierigen Zeiten fakt ist allerdings
auch die Länder stehen für skalisch
besser da als der Bund es ist also recht
und billig wenn sich auch die Länder an
den Mehrkosten ihrer Hochschulen
beteiligen der Bund sieht sich klar als
Anwalt von Wissenschaft und Forschung
und dazu gehört das werden um starke
Allianzen denn nur erfolgreich sind wir
wenn wir gemeinsam arbeiten das gilt
auch für die Entlastung der Studierenden
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler die 200
europaschale die Zahl der Bund aber die
Auszahlung der brauchen wir die Länder
wir haben geprüft gibt es einen
zentralen Weg wie das Geld auf die
Konten kommt Familienkassen
Krankenkassen Finanzämter funktioniert
nicht KfW geht auch nicht wir reden über
Millionen Studierende und
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler an
tausenden Hochschulen und Schulen wer wo
eingeschrieben ist das wissen nur die
Länder dort ist es bekannt für die 200
euro-pauschale wird es eine zentrale
Online-Plattform geben für einen
möglichst schlankes Verfahren der Bund
bezahlt die Plattform Sachsen-Anhalt
unsere Länder auf der unser Partner auf
der Länderseite hat die Weichen schon
gestellt wir haben den Zug aufs Gleis
gesetzt wir handeln nach der Devise
der Bund macht
der Bund macht alles was möglich ist die
Länder kommen dazu wo es nötig ist und
ich gehe auch davon aus dass die Länder
ein Interesse daran haben die jungen
Menschen zu entlassen und liebe Freunde
von der Union liebe Frau Ludwig mir ist
noch ein Einsatz von ihnen aus der
letzten Debatte im Ohr geblieben sie
haben gesagt ich zitiere Ministerium im
Tiefschlaf wenn sie mich angreifen in
Ordnung wir sind politische Akteurinnen
wir sind im Wettstreit aber wenn sie
Vorurteile gegen Beamte und Angestellte
im Ministerium schüren dann ist das
billig sie haben 16 Jahren dieses
Ministerium geführt
sie kennen die Menschen die dort
arbeiten unter Hochdruck alles geben für
gute Bildung in unserem Land für gute
Forschung und ihr Parteivorsitzender hat
vor kurzem sich über die politischen
Stil in der Auseinandersetzung beschwert
ich würde mal sagen bitte nehmen Sie
sich das zu Herzen das geht auch anders
wir haben
wir haben zusammen
Energiekrise der 200 Euro pauschale
liegen die dreifache Entlastung der
Bafög-Empfänger voraus durch die
bafög-reform heizkostenzuschlag 1
heizkostenzuschlag zwei eine dreifache
Entlastung die es jetzt auch vorgesehen
für die wissenschaftlichen Einrichtung
für die Zukunft unseres Landes denn
Wissenschaft löst jeden Tag ein neues
Rätsel wir brauchen sie vielen Dank
bevor ich die nächste Rednerin Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
der Kollege ja zombeck aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Bundesministerin sie haben sich gerade
beklagt wir hätten ihr Haus als im
Tiefschlaf befindend bezeichnet das
Frauenministerin bezieht sich nur auf
die Führungsebene und darauf dass wir
hören das ganz viele Beamten und Beamten
nicht durchdringen mit ihren mit ihren
Anliegen die Kurzintervention deshalb
weil sie vorhin ausgeführt haben es geht
bei diesem härtefallfonds zudem wir sie
übrigens getrieben haben durch eine
Bundestagsdebatte am Tag der Debatte
unseres Antrags haben sie den
härtefallfond angekündigt sie wussten zu
dem Zeitpunkt aber nicht mehr wie groß
er ist oder für wen er gilt jetzt wissen
wir es er gilt nur für die
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen und sie haben
vorhin von Teilchenbeschleuniger von
Rechenzentrum von all diesen Dingen
gesprochen gestern in der Anhörung im
Bildungsausschuss hat Professor Wörner
für die TU Darmstadt da gelegt das genau
diese Einrichtung an dieser Uni da sind
und die Hochschulen sind ausgeschlossen
ich frage Sie an dieser Stelle warum
haben sie die Hochschulen ausgenommen
die TU9 die Technischen Universitäten
wären allemal notwendig mit
berücksichtigt zu werden ist im
härtefallfonds der jedenfalls nach all
dem was hier gerade kolportiert wird
ausschließlich für die universitären
Forschungseinrichtungen gilt
Frau Ministerin
Herr Kollege ja zombeck ich empfehle
Ihnen das Lesen unseres Grundgesetzes
und dem Aufbau der föderalen Struktur
die Hochschulen sind in der
Verantwortung der Länder wir entziehen
uns dieser Verantwortung aber in keiner
Weise zukunftsvertragsstudium und Lehre
Professorinnen Programm und viele
gemeinsame Programme und jetzt die zwei
Milliarden für die
energiepreisbremsen der Bund steht da
und wir arbeiten mit den Ländern
zusammen
soweit sozusagen der kurze Austausch
zwischen Thomas jazzomberg im Sprecher
für Bildung und Forschung der
Unionsfraktion und der Bundesministerin
für Bildung und Forschung Bettina stark
Watzinger hier noch einmal um die Frage
der Einbeziehung von Institutionen in
den härtefallfonds nächste Rednerin
niederstar für die Bündnis grüne
Fraktion
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Frau
Präsidentin lieber Herr Minister Frau
Ministerin liebe Kolleginnen liebe Gäste
es ist gut dass wir heute die Strom- und
gaspreisbremsen auf den Weg bringen und
damit unmittelbar spürbare Entlastung
für jeden Privathaushalt schaffen ich
möchte aber jetzt auch noch mal weil es
nicht nur für die private Haushalte gilt
den Blick lenken wie die Ministerin das
auch schon getan hat auf die
Bildungswissenschaft und
Forschungseinrichtungen ganz herzlichen
Dank auch an Minister Habeck und das
ganze Team des bmwk dass bei diesem
Paket Bildung und Forschung von Anfang
an mitgedacht wurde
Bildung und Forschung sind so elementar
wichtig für unsere Gesellschaft sie
dürfen nicht noch einmal in einer Krise
hinten runterfallen und es ist gut dass
wir als Ampel in dieser Krise dafür
Sorge tragen
zusätzlich
zusätzlich zu dem Preis Bremsen
unterstützen wir außeruniversitäre
Forschungseinrichtungen die besonders
energieintensive Forschung betreiben mit
dem Härtefall von bis zu 500 Millionen
Euro und das BMBF arbeitet da mit
Hochdruck an der Umsetzung herzlichen
Dank auch dafür und natürlich
weil sie sich Sorgen um die Hochschule
machen leisten auch die Länder einen
Beitrag und ich freue mich als
Berlinerin ganz besonders dass Berlin
beispielsweise 180 Millionen Euro
energiehilfen unter anderem zur
Verfügung stellt für die Hochschulen
weitere 13 Millionen sind für das
Studierendenwerk reserviert im
Nachtragshaushalt und herzlichen Dank
dafür an die zuständigen Kollegen in
Berlin
wer entlasten aber nicht nur die
Bildungsinstitutionen für unterstützen
auch Studierende Auszubildende und
Schüler in ganz direkt heute werden wir
nämlich auch die 200 € Einmalzahlung für
alle Studierenden beschließen im
parlamentarischen Verfahren haben wir
durchgesetzt dass das auch für
promotionsstudieren gilt und es ist auch
gut dass alle ausländischen studieren
die hier wohnen diese 200 € bekommen und
ausnahmsweise
hier mal was richtig verstanden Herr
Frömming die 200 Euro fangen nicht die
gesamten Kosten auf sondern wir haben
deshalb zusätzlich ein ganzes Paket an
Maßnahmen auf den Weg gebracht zwei
Heizkostenzuschüsse
energiepreispauschale Kindergelderhöhung
massiver Ausweitung des bafögsbezugs und
vieles mehr damit unterstützen wir
Studierende Fachschule in Auszubildende
und wir denken auch an unsere Bildungs-
und Forschungseinrichtungen und machen
damit Deutschland zukunftsfest
herzlichen Dank
kurze Redebeitrag von Nina von den
Bündnis Grünen ist folgt für die
Unionsfraktion Thomas Gebhardt
Ausschuss für Klimaschutz und Energie
frau Präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren viele Menschen in
unserem Land machen sich in diesen Tagen
sorgen bei einer täglich werde ich von
Bürgern gefragt wie können wir noch
unsere Rechnungen für Strom und Gas und
Öl und Holz bezahlen und Unternehmen
schildern wir die hohen Preise Gefährten
massiv ihre Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und
tatsächlich stehen einige vor dem Aus in
dieser Situation muss der Staat
finanziell unterstützen das ist denke
ich keine Frage wir sind uns hier im
Deutschen Bundestag in dieser Frage auch
grundsätzlich einig dass wir Menschen
und Unternehmen schnell unter die Arme
greifen das sagen wir seit Wochen und
Zeit Monaten aber was ist geschehen es
gab ein Hot in der Bundesregierung bis
in den September hinein haben sie
zunächst an dieser gescheiterten
gasumlage geklammert und sich dann erst
auf den Weg gemacht hin zu einer
energiepreisbremse und bei dieser
Vorgeschichte ist es ja kein Wunder dass
diese energiepreisbremse auf den
allerletzten Drücker kommt und sie ist
unausgegoren ich will es an drei Punkten
deutlich machen der erste Punkt die
Vorschläge der Bundesregierung sie sind
viel zu bürokratisch die Fachleute sagen
uns in Teilen gar nicht verständlich
nicht umsetzbar und mich würde es nicht
wundern wenn wir in den nächsten Wochen
in der Umsetzung dieser gaspreisbremse
und strompreisbremse ein Chaos erleben
würden der zweite Punkt die Preisbremse
ist ungerecht sie ist ungerecht weil sie
vergessen die Millionen von Menschen die
mit Öl oder mit Holz heizen müssen auch
diese erleben enorme Preissteigerungen
aber die Bundesregierung gibt darauf
überhaupt gar keine Antwort sie reden
nur über Gas und das ist nicht in
Ordnung und das ist ein Schlag ins
Gesicht des ländlichen Raums wo
besonders viele zum Heizen auf Öl und
Holz angewiesen sind
und meine Damen und Herren sie wollen
bei den erneuerbaren Energien abschöpfen
wir wollen doch das Deutschland und in
Deutschland mehr investiert wird in
erneuerbare Energien aber sie riskieren
mit ihrem Vorschlag genau das Gegenteil
das weniger investiert wird und wenn sie
das so umsetzen dann wird auch ihr aus
ihrer Preisbremse in Wahrheit eine
Investitionsbremse und das ist das
Letzte was Deutschland im Moment
gebrauchen kann und bei der Bioenergie
hat alleine die Ankündigung des Gesetzes
Schaden angerichtet sie würden die
Bioenergie ab das ist fatal ist doch die
Bioenergie eine verlässliche eine
regelbare und eine heimische Energieform
die wir brauchen meine Damen und Herren
an die Bundesregierung verstärken sie
nicht noch weiter die ohne hin
bestehende Energie Knappheit Deutschland
macht jetzt
sehr sehr viele Schulden um für ein
gutes Jahr die hohen Preise teilweise
abzufedern aber ich frage was kommt
eigentlich danach wir ermöglichen wir
das Unternehmen auch über diese Zeit
hinaus wettbewerbsfähig bleiben wie
ermöglichen wir das die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger in diesem Land auch über diese
Zeit hinaus ihre Strom und Gas und
holzrechnung bezahlen können meine Damen
und Herren hohe Preise sind immer
Ausdruck von Knappheit Energie ist knapp
und deswegen ist es doch jetzt das Gebot
der Stunde dass wir alles dafür tun dass
Angebot zu erhöhen wir müssen
investieren und wir müssen für die
notwendige Infrastruktur Sorgen ich will
nur einen Punkt nennen wir müssen jetzt
Vollgas geben bei der
Wasserstofftechnologie wir brauchen doch
auch dann verlässlich Energie Mensch
Wind und Sonne nicht zur Verfügung
stehen wasserstoff ist ein Schlüssel
dazu und um nachdrücklicher nach dem
Wegfall des russischen Gases gilt wir
haben hier überhaupt keine Zeit zu
verlieren und ich kann nicht verstehen
dass die Bundesregierung jetzt in diesen
Tagen gerade ihr Konzept zur
wasserstoffnetzentwicklung um ein ganzes
Jahr verschoben hat das können wir uns
nicht leisten machen Sie dieses Konzept
sorgen Sie dafür dass Deutschland
schnell wasserstoffland Nummer eins wird
weiterhin die erste Lesung in den
energiepreisbremsen zwei Gesetzentwürfe
durch die Bundesregierung und bereits
die Abstimmung für die Unterstützung für
junge Menschen in Ausbildung nächster
Redner Sebastian Roloff SPD-Fraktion
werte Frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wir diskutieren heute
nichts weniger als eine der größten
Entlastungen für Bürgerinnen und Bürger
seit Bestehen der Bundesrepublik bin
sehr froh dass die Ampel
Handlungsfähigkeit bewiesen hat und wir
dieses Finanzvolumen von 200 Milliarden
heute auf den Weg bringen es ist wichtig
dass wir es möglichst schnell in
sinnvolle wirksame und natürlich
möglichst zielgenaue wo das aus
technischen Gründen möglich ist
Konzepte gießen und dementsprechend
haben wir heute mit diesen Beratungen in
großen Fortschritt gemacht aber auch die
ersten drei entlastungspakete der Ampel
waren weitreichende Unterstützungen
allen voran zum Beispiel der Dezember
Abschlag der in diesen Wochen beginnt zu
wirken und eine erste wichtige
Überbrückungshilfe ist die auch viele
Sorgen von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern auf
der einen und von Unternehmen auf der
anderen Seite ernst nimmt und heute
heute sprechen wir über das noch größere
Paket die gaspreisbremse wird zusammen
mit den unterschiedlich konzipierten
härtefallfonds bis ins Jahr 2024 hinein
Sicherheit geben niemand wird in
Deutschland frieren müssen weil die
Rechnung nicht mehr bezahlbar ist und
das muss unser gemeinsames Anliegen sein
natürlich ist klar dass diese Bremse
teuer ist aber nicht zu handeln wäre
noch teurer es gäbe ganz gravierende
Verwerfungen die Industrialisierung
Arbeitsplatzverluste und dementsprechend
ist es wichtig jetzt hier staatlich
Regeln einzugreifen klar ist aber auch
und das haben wir bei der Konzeption
bedacht dass wir natürlich auch
Sparanreize schaffen müssen und das ist
in dem Konzept vorgesehen ich freue mich
ganz besonders weil ich es mir auch fast
ein bisschen gewünscht habe als ich das
letzte Mal hier an der Stelle stand dass
wir eine rückwirkende Entlastung ab
Januar hinbekommen es hat in den
Gesprächen Gott sei Dank funktioniert
und auch das ist genau das richtige
Signal an die Unternehmen in diesem Land
es ist jetzt richtig dass Bürgerinnen
und Bürger und Unternehmen konkret
planen können wann kommt welche
Belastung wann kommen welche
preisbremsen wann können wir kalkulieren
und es ist unsere Aufgabe als Politik
ergänzen zu gucken dass wir auch die
Liquidität von Unternehmen sicherstellen
weil auch wenn es rückwirkend gilt bis
März natürlich auch ein gewisser
Zeitraum zu überbrücken ist darüber
hinaus ist die gaspreisbremse auch
volkswirtschaftlich richtig wir haben es
heute schon gehört sie wird inflations
dämpfend wirken es wird eine spürbare
Entlastung auch diesbezüglich sein und
dementsprechend ist das genau der
richtige Weg den wir gehen zum Abschluss
darf ich noch mal ganz ausdrücklich auch
seitens der SPD-Fraktion feststellen
dass wir diese Diskussionen über einen
gesund Schrumpfen der Industrie oder der
deutschen Wirtschaft etwas fehlgeleitet
finden wir stehen an der Seite der
Beschäftigten und es geht nicht um den
Industrialisierung es geht um
Transformationen und hier braucht es
mutige Schritte
wir werden die Weichen so stellen dass
wir langfristig erfolgreich sind
konkurrenzfähiger industriestrompreis
ebenso wie eine Reform des Marit
order-prinzips und natürlich auch den
Aufbau der erneuerbaren Energien ich
darf zum Abschluss sagen bin
außerordentlich stolz dass wir diese
Gesetze heute auf den Weg bringen vielen
Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion DR
Andreas Lenz
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir sehen uns
mit der Ampel einig dass wir
Entlastungen brauchen wir das Wasser war
dann auch schon mit der Einigkeit die
Entlassungen kommen zu spät sie sind zu
bürokratisch und sie sind auch noch
ungerecht unsere Vorschläge liegen seit
Anfang des Jahres auf dem Tisch sie
haben es versäumt im Sommer über ein
tagfähiges Konzept zu entwickeln und
stattdessen lieber um die gasumlage
gestritten die nicht nur Unsinn sondern
auch
verfassungswidrig gewesen wäre und sie
machen gleich weiter zuerst wollen sie
die von Ihnen als zufallsgewinne
titulierten Erträge aus Erneuerbaren
rückwirkend bis jetzt abschöpfen
verfassungsrechtlich auch zweifelhaft
dann ab September jetzt ab Dezember das
schafft kein Klima für Investitionen in
der erneuerbare das Gegenteil wird damit
erzeugt sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ein grün ein grün geführtes Ministerium
verunsichert beim Ausbau der
Erneuerbaren das muss man sich erst
einmal vorstellen meine Damen und Herren
bei den Preis Bremsen schaffen sie neue
bürokratische Monster die vorliegenden
Vorschläge sind so nicht verständlich
und daher nicht umsetzbar das sagt nicht
ich das sagt Frau Andrea von Bibi die
sehr gut kennen müssten und zwar sagt
sie das noch letzte und diese Woche
schaffen sie endlich Klarheit und
Umsetzbarkeit meine Damen und Herren
Biogas biogasmus anders behandelt werden
als PV und Wind hier wurde oft genau das
gemacht was wir brauchen und was wir
wollen hier wurde flexibilisiert hier
wurde investiert um für das Gesamtsystem
entsprechend bei den Nachfrage Spitzen
System dienlich zu sein diejenigen die
hier investiert haben dürfen nicht dafür
bestraft werden meine Damen und Herren
und dafür stehen wir als Union die Ampel
will sogenannte zufallsgewinne bei
Biogas PV und Wind abschöpfen bei
Steinkohlekraftwerken aber nicht weil
die laut Ministerium notwendig sind um
Erdgas beim verstromen zu sparen
Kernkraftwerke zur Stromerzeugung will
man aber stilllegen so kann man das
Zusammenfassen ihre Energiepolitik passt
doch hinten und vorne nicht zusammen
meine Damen und Herren
sie haben immer noch keine hinreichende
Lösung wie sie Bürger mit Holzpellet mit
Holz mit Heizöl Heizungen entlasten
wollen auch hier brauchen wir
entsprechende Lösungen und nicht den
Gang zum Jobcenter natürlich 200
Milliarden Euro das ist ein wuchtiges
Paket wir müssen aber schon auch
berücksichtigen das Geld nicht wird
nicht investiert es wird nichts gebaut
es wird nichts modernisiert es wird
nicht erneuert es wird lediglich
konsultiert da ist ja die Ampel auch
entsprechend spezialisiert in den USA
wird gleichzeitig ein sogenannter in
Flächen reduction Act ins Leben gerufen
mit einem Volumen von fast 500 Millionen
Milliarden Dollar und dort wird
investiert und wir müssen in Deutschland
auch wieder investieren ist rot nichts
weniger als die die Industrialisierung
des Landes wir müssen alles aber auch
wirklich alles daran setzen dass wir in
Deutschland und Europa auch zukünftig
wettbewerbsfähig sind dass der Mittel
ist das Produkt produzierende Gewerbe
dass die Industrie auch hier
Perspektiven haben die Chemieindustrie
erwartet mehr oder weniger unbeachtet
von der Öffentlichkeit
2022 einen Produktionsrückgang von 8,5
Prozent und durch die 70% Grenze bei der
gaspreisbremse werden Anreize gesetzt
weniger Gas zu verbrauchen das stimmt
aber eben auch weniger Anreize oder es
werden auch Anreize gesetzt weniger zu
produzieren wenn du wenn die Industrie
aber weg ist dann gibt es auch nichts
mehr zu transformieren dann gibt es eben
auch keine keinen Weg hin zur
CO2-Neutralität und keine Arbeitsplätze
in Deutschland wir brauchen also einen
Mittelstand wir brauchen einen
Industriestrom Tarif wir brauchen CO2
neutrale Geschäftsmodelle und keine
Überregulierung und wir brauchen
insgesamt mehr Perspektiven für den
Wirtschaftsstandort und führt auch für
den Industriestandort Deutschland
herzlichen Dank
eine der Fragen die im Raum stehen
reichen die avisierten bremsen um auch
kleine und mittlere Unternehmen in
dieser energiepreiskrise zu retten und
am Leben zu halten diese Frage wird sich
später beantworten für die SPD-Fraktion
jetzt Lina Seidel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren Herr Kollege jetzt Homberg
ich möchte dann doch noch mal dran
erinnern dass in der gestrigen Anhörung
im Ausschuss für Bildung und Forschung
alle Sachverständigen und zwar von
Hochschulrektorenkonferenz bis zu den
außeruniversitären
Forschungseinrichtungen gesagt haben
dass sie sehr profitieren von den
Maßnahmen die die Bundesregierung in den
letzten Wochen und Monaten in Kraft
gesetzt hat und natürlich auch von den
energiepreisbremsen über die wir hier
gerade sprechen
der Deutsche Ethikrat hat vor ein paar
Tagen eine AD hoc-empfehlung zum
besseren Schutz der jungen Generation
veröffentlicht er geht darin auf die
psychischen Belastung ein mit denen
Kinder Jugendliche und junge Erwachsene
in den letzten knapp drei Jahren umgehen
mussten und ich will mit Erlaubnis der
Präsidentin gerne dessen Vorsitzenden
der dessen Vorsitzende Alena Burgs
zitieren die gesagt hat wir schulden als
Gesellschaft Kindern Jugendlichen und
jungen Erwachsenen nicht nur Dank und
Respekt sondern konkretes Handeln die
Zeit der corona-pandemie wurde von
jungen Menschen als große emotionale in
vielen Fällen auch existenzielle Krise
wahrgenommen und darf sie in eine nicht
zuvor gekannte Belastungssituation dann
kam der völkerrechtswidrige
Angriffskrieg Russland auf die Ukraine
oder die damit verbundenen
Preissteigerungen die zum Beispiel für
Studierende die gerade von zu Hause
ausgezogen sind und so sowieso wenig
Geld in der Tasche haben besonders zu
spüren sind und über all dem liegt
natürlich auch die Sorge von dem
Klimawandel dessen Auswirkungen
wäre die junge Generation zu spüren
bekommen wird wenn wir ihn nicht in den
Krieg Griff bekommen und diese
Überlagerung von Ausnahmezuständen für
junge Menschen darf nicht übersehen
werden sie haben sich in den letzten
Jahren solidarisch gezeigt und
Einschränkungen hingenommen und deshalb
schulden wir dieser Generation als
gesellschaftssolidarität und
Unterstützung und für uns als politik
bedeutet das dann eben auch neben Worten
der Anerkennung Taten folgen zu lassen
wie von Alena Burg fordert und deshalb
bin ich wirklich sehr froh dass wir
heute den Gesetzesentwurf zur Energie-
und damit und damit ist es ja nicht
getan ich habe das hier immer wieder
betont und die Ministerin Frau stark
Watzinger hat es gerade auch noch mal
aufgeführt wir haben ja bereits eine
Kette von Maßnahmen verabschiedet die
Erhöhung Öffnung des BAföG die
Verankerung des nothilfe-mechanismus
Anhebung Mindestlohn Minijob Grenze und
so weiter und so fort und natürlich
profitiert diese Gruppe von Menschen
auch von den energiepreisbremsen über
die wir ja gerade auch beraten und die
wir dann im Dezember verabschieden
werden und Sie sehen das ist ein
bemerkenswertes Paket an Maßnahmen die
wir hier in den letzten Monaten
beschlossen haben aber die besten
Beschlüsse nutzen natürlich nichts wenn
sie dann erst sehr spät ankommen wir
haben hier parlamentarisch jetzt den Weg
frei gemacht für eine schnelle
Auszahlung der 200 Euro und jetzt liegt
das an Bundesministerium und auch an den
Ländern die tatsächliche Zahlungen dann
zügig vorauszugehen ich möchte zum
Schluss noch mal ähm eindringlich dafür
werden das auch in dieser Energiekrise
Schulen und Hochschulen unbedingt offen
bleiben müssen damit steigende Kosten
eben nicht noch weiter an diese Gruppe
abgeschoben werden und damit nach fast
drei Jahren der pandemiebedingten
Einschränkungen der Austausch und die
Begegnung junger Menschen gefördert
statt beschränkt werden kann vielen Dank
wir gehen langsam in die Schlusskurve in
diesem
Tagesordnungspunkt 7 über die
energiepreisbremse und die Studierenden
energiepauschale so wie es hier benannt
ist von der Tagungsleitung die letzte
Rednerin Jessica Rosenthal SPD die
Juso-Vorsitzende in ihrem Leben Amt
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir diskutieren
heute in erster Lesung die Gas- und
strompreisbremse und bringen damit wie
auch schon vielfach unterstrichen
wichtige Entlastungen auf den Weg denn
gerade einkommensschwache Haushalte
trifft diese Krise besonders hart die
einkommensschwächsten 20 Prozent wenden
62% ihres Konsums für Nahrungsmittel
wohnen und Energie auf das bedeutet dass
sie bis zu fünf Mal so stark belastet
sind in dieser Krise als alle anderen
und gerade deshalb ist es auch so
wichtig dass wir heute und hier und
jetzt in zweiter und dritter Lesung die
energiepreispauschale für Studierende
und Fachschülerinnen beraten
denn wer sind denn die
einkommensschwachen Gruppen es sind
Studierende und Azubis Azubis haben oft
ein sehr kleines Einkommen sie müssen
diese Kosten für eine eigene Wohnung
aufwenden für Lebensmittel davon auch
noch die Energiepreise Bezahlen im
ersten Lehrjahr verdient ein eine
Friseur eine
Auszubildende im Friseurhandwerk 585
Euro eine im Fleischerei Handwerk sind
es dann schon 736 aber mal ehrlich wer
soll in dieser Zeit davon leben können
und deshalb ist es gut und richtig dass
wir mit der Reform des Bafögs eben auch
die Berufsausbildungsbeihilfe reformiert
haben dass da mehr ankommt für
Auszubildende dass wir den
Heizkostenzuschuss auf den Weg gebracht
haben dass wir jetzt auch mit dem
Programm jungen wohnen was auf den Weg
bringen um das Wohnen bezahlbar zu
machen und dass wir die 300 € auch für
Studierende auf den Weg gebracht haben
aber von die auch für auszubilden auf
dem Weg gebracht haben von diesen 300
Euro haben eben nicht alle
Auszubildenden profitiert gerade die die
im schulischen Bereich eine Ausbildung
machen und das sind viele junge Menschen
in diesem Land die haben nicht
profitiert wir reden dabei von den
erziehungs- und Gesundheitsberufen wir
reden dabei von notfallsanitäterin
Gesundheits- und Krankenpflegerin von
Heilerziehungspflegerin von
Erzieherinnen das sind doch die Berufe
die gerade in der corona-pandemie für
uns alle so viel gestemmt haben und
deshalb müssen jetzt
gerade diese Ausbildungsberufe auch die
200 Euro bekommen das ist eine Frage des
Respekts und genau deshalb bringen wir
das jetzt auf den Weg 200 Euro auch für
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler das
muss kommen bitte stimmen Sie zu vielen
Dank
ja soweit Jessica Rosenthal von der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion sie ist die
letzte Rednerin gewesen hier in dieser
Debatte um die Energiepreis Bremse und
die Studierenden energiepauschale Top 7
vielleicht sie haben es sicher bemerkt
an ihrem River das ist nicht die erste
Rednerin gewesen mit der roten Schleife
warum 1988 hat die
Weltgesundheitsorganisation den ersten
Dezember zum Welt AIDS Tag ausgerufen
und das ist das Zeichen heute dafür wir
gehen jetzt in die Abstimmung für die
Studierenden energiepauschale
für Studierende Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler sowie berufsfachschülerin
und Berufsfachschüler in Bildungsgängen
mit dem Ziel eines mindestens
zweijährigen berufsqualifizierenden
Abschluss ist der Ausschuss für Bildung
und Forschung und
Technikfolgenabschätzung empfiehlt in
seiner Beschlussempfehlung auf
Drucksache
4741 den Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der
SPD Bündnis 90 die Grünen und FDP auf
Drucksache
4.536 anzunehmen hierzu liegt ein
Änderungsantrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
auf Drucksache
4.744 vor über den wir zuerst abstimmen
wer stimmt für diesen Änderungsantrag
das ist die Fraktion der cdu/csu wer
stimmt dagegen
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
mindestens 90 die Grünen die FDP wer
enthält sich das ist die afd-fraktion
damit ist der Änderungsantrag abgelehnt
ich bitte nun diejenigen die dem
Gesetzentwurf der Fraktion der SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP auf Drucksache
4.536 zustimmen wollen um das
Handzeichen
das sind die Fraktionen die Linke SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt dagegen
niemand
Enthaltungen die afd-fraktion damit ist
der Gesetzentwurf
in zweiter Beratung angenommen dritte
Beratung und Schlussabstimmung ich bitte
diejenigen die dem Gesetzentwurf
zustimmen wollen sich zu erheben
das sind die die Fraktionen die Linke
SPD
Bündnis 90 die Grünen FDP
cdu/csu-fraktion Enthaltungen
ja ich mache es mir jetzt einfacher
Enthaltung die afd-fraktion Gegenstimmen
niemand
der Gesetzentwurf ist damit angenommen
jetzt braucht es nur noch diese digitale
Plattform und dann kann das Geld auch
fließen aber da müssen noch viele Hände
mitmachen Antrag der Fraktion der
cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4.677 mit dem Titel
200 Euro Einmalzahlung jetzt an Studie
Studenten und Studenten sowie
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler
auszahlen wer stimmt für diesen Antrag
das ist die cdu/csu-fraktion wer stimmt
dagegen das ist sind die
Fraktionen die Linke SPD Bündnis 90 die
Grünen FDP und Enthaltungen die
afd-fraktion damit ist der Antrag
abgelehnt